so after I posted your
video
um one of my loyal viewers who watches
all the videos I think said that you've
interviewed this person before and I'm
like I don't think so you were you were
you look so drastically different the
glasses and the your whole look was was
extremely different I I have I tend to
change my style a lot um well that day I
didn't tell you for a perfect reason I
really needed the money and you didn't
say anything about that you had seen me
before so I didn't let you know that hey
I've been here before you know it's uh
part of but you you look so much more
together the first time I interviewed
you than then last time you looked
pretty crazy
really
okay I still look crazy today too what
is that is that the bipolar thing just
yeah uming it head I've been having a
lot of man episodes lately I I've been
screaming at the I've been having this
voice in my head and it's um spiritual
and I've been screaming at it to leave
me alone like you know stop trying to be
with me stop trying to love me and let
me find somebody because the people who
come around me end
up being ushered out really fast like um
the spirit because I believe that God is
um
very powerful and it's not just because
you can't I don't I don't see this
Spirit or listen to it as it is God
because there's so much Evil coming from
it but there's so much good when he's
not mad or she's not mad whatever it is
and it's wanting to control my life it
even told me in my head one time that it
wanted to be me to let I needed to die
so it could be me and um
to that that's that it's supposed to
be in in essence ended up being me and I
was like cuz I had a whole point where
an angel had kissed me and I'm not going
to mention your names but an angel
kissed me and the face was there and
uh God won't let me be talking to that
person or even think about being in a
relationship with them because God told
me that God loves me and doesn't want to
see me with someone else but all my life
is doing is being in turmoil I'm alone I
am always broke when I do buy something
such as drugs I end up breaking like
dropping it just perfect and it breaks
or I lose it and God talks to me the
spirit talks to me is like you know
that's why you lost it because you
shouldn't be doing it I don't want you
to do it and I'm like well you see and
it it has it goes through the pain with
me and has empathy so I'm like when you
go through the this pain with me and you
have the empathy you see that you're
putting me back through it when I had to
be again back out here on the streets
find a way to get the little bit of
money to get what I need just for you to
throw it away again you seen that I've
been beat up you seen that I have to lie
sometimes you see that I have no not a
real life because nine times out of 10
my life is trying to find what I need
and then when I do you end up tearing it
up on me you know is this is this
schizophrenia that you're dealing with
it's spiritual and I think it's
schizophrenia but I've never been
diagnosed with it it's just bipolar I've
been diagnosed with right no but I I I
suspect after doing so many interviews
and seeing people on meth who stay of
how often do you sleep um I sleep I go
like at least one to two nights if I do
meth without sleeping but I have been
doing pretty well to stay off meth it's
the um pain medicine that I've had a
problem with what are you taking now um
Fetti fit all oh wow so yeah and it's
not cheap so I try to get around $10 to
$20 a day and it'll last me sometimes
two days but the way I've
been fighting the spirit and everything
is seems like I know more than get in
the door and I'm right back out the door
again trying to make more money yeah it
just seems like when people are staying
up night after night mhm it's more
cytosis things yeah things like
schizophrenia whether they're actually
schizophrenia what is the spirit talking
to me because it's not me talking to
myself and I hear it it's like a
conversation it brings to light things
that I wouldn't even be thinking of so
I'm like where is this voice coming from
you know and it's a a well-meaning voice
or is it uh it's a the spirit is in love
with me and um also hates me it wants to
cause it it's like have you ever seen
the um movie with um Thor and all that
never saw it okay well it's like the
low-key character for the gods it has a
trickster Soul it likes to trick me and
laugh at me and all that stuff and they
don't think about the pain behind it or
or what us as humans or what we are
bodied going through because it's not us
it's a it's not um in essence a human
being i' I've gathered that much
information because of how it um told me
many times that if I seen the form that
it is I would wouldn't love it or I'd be
scared of
it so whatever form it is I believe it's
like some kind of um extraterrestrial
form maybe it's back when you know the
Mayans and stuff um did the pictographs
and all that of the extraterrestrial
alien crafts and stuff I believe it's
whatever had us mining for gold and was
having the pyramids built and um uh that
that Circle went over there um the one
with the big Stones all that stuff is
from different races that have been on
Earth there's been the um the Giants and
all that and so whatever has been doing
our genetic codes splicing and um
breeding us and abducting us there's so
many um times that people have the same
story and not have talked to each other
and not been in the same town or
anything of being held by these
creatures so I'm I'm knowing that it's
one of them and but many have come
lately and have inhabited different
parts of this world they're stepping in
and out of us there's a creature that on
the spirits there's many of them at some
point they're watching and um trying to
I believe help me because a lot of them
um have been trying to be protective
well they told me that when I smoke
fentanyl or Fetti it steps out of me
they said that that um the spirit that
actually kiss me the angel is in a
relationship with that spirit in another
um level of existence and it looks like
me and it's connected inside of me so it
steps out of my being when like say I
smoke fit and all it doesn't want to do
those things but it pretty much took on
the Persona of me and is in a
relationship with the spirit that I had
kissed
me and there's a lot there's a lot going
on your head it is a lot what what am I
calling you am I calling you uh Rob or
am I calling you Brian you can call me
Robert or Bob or Brian or or um
Brandon yeah McKinley I never get called
that that's my midle middle name I see
so um I I sometimes go by my
grandfather's name that's Rob and my
father's name I don't never go by it
it's ter so but um but you so you've
been you've been on the streets for for
how
long over 12 years it seems like like
the first interview I did of you you
looked much yeah you you you looked and
spoke much
more like you were much together
coherent and everything yeah it's like
lately it's been a drastically a
downhill grade is there stuff in the
drugs or are the drugs just taking a
toll on you I'm fighting it with freedom
to do what I want to do it doesn't want
me to do the drugs so that pushes me to
do more it doesn't want me to be happy
with anyone so that pushes me to go out
and meet somebody and I'm going to I'm
going to fight this thing with
everything that I have and I'm going to
let it know yes I love you and if you
are my maker you're going to love me
back and you're going to accept and
appreciate what I am and who I am and
you're going to quit trying to change me
for who you want me to be you've already
told me you want me to die and you take
over my body and for somehow you're in
another realm and uh look it told me
many times that it looks like me many of
the songs and the uh signs and the
signals I've been getting from songs and
people is that it the other me is
trapped in the mirror but it's more like
not trapped in the mirror but another
realm it's some kind of spirit to do
with me and I'm fighting the evil that
when I was younger I had a lot of bad
thoughts when someone would come around
me I would think you know I didn't know
who they were but if they did something
and like was very comfortable around me
and just acted like they belonged I was
like who the hell do you think you are
you need to go kill yourself like I
would think these bad things so those
thoughts don't enter my mind no more but
there's a voice talking bad things sort
of like that and I'm trying to fight it
I'll talk out loud and in my mind back
to it and I'm like you need to leave me
alone I fought my life to get the evil
out of me and you're you're still
steadily trying to take over and Ru my
life if you truly are God and you're
trying to help my life trying to clean
me up let me do that for myself let me
make that decision for for myself and it
doesn't seem to want to let
off seems like schizophrenia to me yeah
but if you ever had this happen to you
you understand it's true it is
real because many many people are
voicing the same thing The Voice the
voices are are it is it just happened
these past few years that it's gotten
this bad with people is something has
connected with this Earth in this realm
where we're at or maybe there's
something the drugs mm no it's not the
drugs we're all having the same it's a
group hallucination it's um a mass
hallucination it's not there's no way
that what they're putting in the drugs
is a chemical that is genetically or um
technically infused with enough coding
and stuff to have everyone have the same
hallucinations the same voice talking
about the same things and so you're
saying there's there's a a group of
people that are all hallucinating the
well there's the ones that
are it's just whatever if they're trying
to still gauge the Judgment of us
because I've been judged many times I
went to heaven like three times that I
know of in my conscious being knowing I
was in heaven talking to Spirits there
was a line of people we weren't wearing
no clothes the first time and like
halfway through that memory we ended up
being in all white robes I remember we
were in a white place and there was a
line of people and they were coming up
and they were all kissing me and it was
men because I remember when I was first
experiencing this um Spirit stuff I
remember coming into uh coming back to
myself and I was in a building and I was
like how did I get here and I'm signing
a book and when I look up at the wall
the wall was shimmering and it was
emerald seethrough and I was like what
is this so I hurry up and got out of
where I just entered and I'm I'm signing
a book I'm like what am I signing where
am I at and I'm acting like you know I
know this place I stepped out and these
beautiful men walked out behind me and
they're like you're accepted come on in
and I'm like I knew cuz I could see
through the walls and how the entrance
was it was Heaven and it was emerald
seethrough and I was like cuz in the
Bible it says it'll be Jasper clear
walls is clear as Crystal you know
clear's glass but I didn't think that it
would be Green Glass but it's Emerald
color if it's all but I only seen this
one wall and it lifted up off the ground
after I got there talking to other
people there's more that I talk to them
about but it lifted up off the ground
and almost hit a building when it was
leaving it it has the capability to be
what it needs to be at that point in
time the son will talk to me the actual
son we could go outside with the camera
if it would do it and the sun will have
a conversation with me the actual son
I'm the one who went on the mountain and
talked to the sun I remember being the
bird coming back on Noah's Ark and
talking to the um talking to it was
God's spirit in
Noah I had the ability not the ability
but I was given the right to be shown me
in that interaction I was outside
viewing what I had been my spirit was
the bird do you think you are the chosen
one that the son no I'm not chosen for
nothing there's a lot of people who have
the same hallucinations that I do been
Marilyn Monroe been reenacting these
different parts through history of these
famous people and your persona and your
body is connecting with that spirit and
you feel like you were that person at
one time and you have these memories of
that person we just talked about it
today outside the needle exchange this
lady has these different memories that
she was these people were you somebody
else at one point she named three people
that I remember being too and I said
well is awesome that you got to
experience being that awesome person and
having yourself feel
so exalted and uplifted I'm glad that we
all could do that I'm not like someone
who selfish to be like oh so God's going
to give everybody that feeling you know
I'm not special no I'm glad God did that
for you you know I think kind of it was
worried and wanting me to
feel let down because of how mad I've
been at it who have you been
who have I been when you say you oh okay
so um I've done a lot of work for uh
stars and actors who like in the movies
and stuff that was going to be really
harmed and there was a lot of um
evilness in Hollywood that was going on
and I was standing in for people that
was singers that were getting shot up on
stage at award ceremonies I remember
this and I would stand and not let them
die I remember it was something going on
that Hollywood like something evil hit
and everyone was going through this
thing in the TV the people in the stars
were going through this evilness they
were being um mask kep in these um rooms
and I'm trying to help them all out and
I'm having this power to where I can
unlock it and let them out at some
points and like you know talking with
them like telepathically and everything
so I am I have been working for God and
helping the goodness but to think of the
how heavy and big the evil was that I
was fighting against but I was doing
good and I was doing it yes God and the
angels and the goodness backing me in my
heart having that Purity knowing that
hey I'm doing something and I know
nothing's going to stop me because I
know I'm doing the right thing I could
have took on the world and I would have
won who who did you
save um I I've been
um let's
see Lana Del has been a huge uh leader
spiritually with talking to me and being
in another realm and like but being
beside me I can't see her but I can hear
her and I see little flashes of people
like sometimes they'll walk in and
you'll see like a car turn and the car
changes like to a different kind of car
it's different things happening to where
you I'm seeing the Realms like the valve
is has a crack in it and so um I've been
talking with Lana Del re I've been
talking with Adele I've been talking
with multiple I I'm a singer I Am god
named me Emmanuel when I was first in my
apartment over here when I first came
off the streets god named me Emanuel he
said you are like my son Jesus you're
you're my son so your name is Emanuel so
because I dated so many Michaels and had
so much spiritual problems with Michaels
they were calling me Michael because of
my ring they said that um cuz I had an M
ring they were saying that my name was
Michael and I said no the m stands for
McKinley that's my middle of name that's
why I have the M ring I ended up taking
the ring off and leaving it on the side
of the road I I was like I'm not having
it but I I went back and got it and then
I lost it again I had my ring last night
a different ring and I was going to take
it off and throw it and the spirit said
don't do it so I went ahead and put it
back on and we were arguing the whole
way home and can you imagine I'm walking
by myself and I am like iate talking to
the spirit sometimes in my head but I'm
like livid and when I get home my Ring's
missing off my finger God went ahead and
said you're not going to have the ring
you're not going to um allow me to
control and be that hand of um whatever
in your life whether it be good or bad
you're not going to be saying that
you're CU I said I have the spirit
because I am I love myself and I love
God and I'm married to God until I find
somebody and God said well then you
going to turn and th the spirit the ring
away because you're not going to be with
me you want to be with who kissed you
and and yes I know who the spirit is and
God keeps telling me that God but God
told me in the beginning when all this
first started happening when I first
started having to help everyone and I
didn't have to I just when I was put in
these situations my um my being knew
what was going to happen it's like I
have a um a medium kind of way or a a
some kind of seeing the future and but
it was a feeling I knew I need to do
this I seen the um design where I got
put into I seen where the design was
coming to where somebody was about to
get hurt so I knew exactly where to
stand what to do who was going to do the
shooting who was going to be the one
getting hurt so I didn't have to ask
nobody nothing was like okay now you
need to take a left and all this stuff
no I did it myself and I was saving all
these people I was praying and my words
were
um causing blessings and saving lives
the Cur verses that they were trying to
put on us and trying to at one point
manipulate us into saying these words
and these phrases to put curses on
ourselves I had to fight that to get to
the point where I'm at right
now so I've been going through a lot and
it's been more than just mental it's
actual
real to you it's 100% real yeah and for
me to not have family my mom and my dad
are both passed away and for me to be
clear across the country from where I'm
from and I'm the Virgo I'm the Virgin
I'm the one who is the water Bearer I am
um Neptune the water God that is not
Jupiter where are you actually from
because I think the one video Alabama
and New York I was in New York for a
long time so you were in both in Florida
too okay and I stopped in Texas on the
way here yeah but you got a little twang
Alabama Alabama yeah my mom was uh
raised in Alabama her father was raised
in Maryland that's a Northern State my
dad was raised in Tennessee and I was
raised on the Alabama Tennessee line so
my dad was a Tennessee Vs fan my mom was
a Alabama Crimson Tide
fan
football all right Brian Rob thank you
so much for coming back in explaining
what's going on I'm glad
you're I I hope that if anybody sees
this and is going through the same thing
that they don't give up and they know
that more of us are going through this
and yes I am a homeless guy who has a
drug problem don't let them tell you and
try to convince you that it's the drug
don't let the Badness get
into thinking that and it's I I
understand I see the goodness trying to
do this for us too trying to say hey you
don't need to see what's going on you
need to somehow be blinded to it too so
I see how it's you know both because if
you think about it God God is all
creation good and bad God is everything
everything that we have and we exist
from is what God created us to be so
when you think about it is Zeus god and
is there a Hades it's the same one so
it's a split personality it's been
bipolar more than I ever could be going
back and forth so don't give up on your
relationship with the spirit and whatat
is whatever you believe your realm to be
believe it to be good use your faith and
good way your words and your actions do
count against your life and for your
life you speak blessings or curses over
your life your words and your actions do
cause an effect karma is a real thing
what you put out you will get back and
sometimes more than what you bargain for
so don't give up though give your heart
and your mind and your surroundings
whether you be homeless or have an
apartment or have a million dollars
you are somebody and you're not going
through everything alone we're all going
through something all right Brian thank
you so much
yeah